grant shaps did know about it some 12
hours beforehand but given that piano
had had done this before he expected to
go in the same manner what's your
response to that i'm deeply unimpressed
by what i saw in parliament yesterday
and i saw some of the media interviews
this morning and the first one says i
get told as the shadow secretary states
sometimes where businesses making
redundancies needs to make changes i
would have been suspicious straight away
that something was being you're being
told your secretary of state and it's
the next morning that doesn't feel right
to me in terms of the notice period the
first thing you always ask is are you in
contact with the trade unions are you
engaged with the workforce there has to
be some times reorganizations everyone
accepts that but
there's too much from the government
right now about let's help those workers
find new jobs for instance no
clearly that might be important but the
priority should be saying this is
unacceptable in this country we will not
have a race to the bottom in standards
the government promised after brexit
that wouldn't be
the case and frankly let's make clear
you've got to reinstate those workers
engage with them properly because i fear
that they have they've priced in this is
the cost of doing business and we just
simply cannot allow that to happen but
aren't aren't we somewhat though in a
holding pattern at least until it is
established whether or not the
legislation the domestic legislation
actually applies to them by my reckoning
you know we've seen this happen to irish
ferries we saw it happen to our company
in scotland before and it was all
perfectly legal because these ships were
not flagged in the united kingdom and
they were sailing outside of uk
territorial waters yes well i believe
they have broken the law i take the
point it's a maritime jurisdiction it's
not a a domiciled business within
wherever they were domiciled in terms of
the registration they would apply if it
was a mainland situation i would just
say as well as that because that was the
excuse from the government yesterday you
remember when we tried to uh strengthen
the law on fire and rehire the central
argument from the government i know this
is not rehired by the way but the other
point still stands the central point
from the government was actually we're
sort of overreacting this legislation
isn't required there are already
protections in place i think we can say
definitively there's one group of
workers who aren't protected and needs
further strengthening of the law why
didn't we see that from the government
yesterday they could acknowledge they
were wrong or they could even say
because this is a maritime situation
it's different let's see the law
strength because we have seen far too
much of this fire and rehire in the
economy and it has no place you know the
workers the workforce of any business or
its greatest asset and i want to see
that from the government be acknowledged
what should those 800 members have got
former members of piano ferry staff what
what should they be doing at the moment
and the suggestion is that if they want
to get the redundancy payment out if
they want to get the nice redundancy
payment out they have to do what i must
say you know plenty of companies
including presumably sky at some point
have done which is you don't get your
payout until you've signed a
non-disclosure agreement
the whole approach from the company to
this from those tactics around the
non-disclosure agreements to the hiring
of
people to forcibly remove staff members
from the first is a disgrace so first of
all i think those workers are doing
everything they can to highlight the
position they're in there some of them
joined us in parliament in the public
gallery yesterday what a great moment
that could have been for the government
to say actually we acknowledge you are
the victims here we're going to work on
a cross-party basis whatever is required
we're going to correct that i don't want
to hear about a task force in the
department of work and pensions i wonder
you're not telling me you had any
expectation that on an opposition day
motion the government was going to fall
in behind you we do often get as you
know they perhaps might vote for our
particular motion but they'll say we
will promise to take this economic crime
bill i was talking about last time was
on the show a good example i don't
accept our amendments in the comments
but they say we accept the argument
essentially we'll go away and do that in
the house of laws or promise to to
legislate in another opportunity as it
stands i've not heard anything from the
government to say they will prevent this
happening in future let alone correct
this injustice i don't think that's good
enough
let's talk about what may well be coming
down the pipeline the spring statement
of course coming tomorrow i mean in an
ideal world what would you want to hear
from rishi sunak apart from you know do
you fancy doing the job
well the justice should consider himself
fortunate i would say to have an
opportunity to directly address this
enormous cost of living crisis and
pressure there is on families the two
things i would want at a minimum would
be first of all the chancellor not make
the situation worse so don't proceed
with that large rise to national
insurance for employers and employees
there's no other g7 country raising
taxes on working people given the
pressures in the global economy
particularly inflation on farms the
other thing is he's got to take action
real action on energy bills so the thing
he announced before that the buy now per
later scheme well that was never
particularly impressive but when you
think about the fact that it's based on
the idea energy bills will fall in
future well that's obsolete so he's got
to change that we favor that windfall
tax use the revenue that's already come
into the exchequer from the v80 and
existing taxation receipts and take some
real action so take vat off energy bills
everyone's going to gain from that
change some of the levees so you're
taking those off bills as well hugely
expand warm homes discount in terms of
its generosity and eligibility so the
result of that would be 200 pounds off
an energy bill for everybody and 600
pounds for about a third of households
the people who are most severely hit by
this that's the kind of real action we
need to see and i am worried that he's
trying to play down
this whole statement rather than say i'm
the chancellor people are facing these
unprecedented pressures i'm going to
help you would the labour party support
the government if it announced a plan to
build in short in a short space of time
a number of small nuclear reactors
someone pointed out the detail to me
yesterday we've got a handful in this
country just across the channel the
french have got in excess of 50 of them
would labor party support going to
return to nuclear yes we would we want
to see more nuclear in the system we
extended the life of well most of the
more modern nuclear power stations in
government
at the end of that time there was the
need to get new nuclear on the system to
replace some of the outgoing plants it
hasn't happened for 12 years so the
government get on with that you can't
build them too quickly is the honest
truth around that there's some exciting
new technology smaller modular reactors
but again that will take some time to
come online but new nuclear has to be
part of the system but also let's
reverse the ban on onshore wind in this
country we've lost enough capacity there
that is equivalent effectively in energy
terms to the entirety of our of our gas
imports from russia so there are real
things that could be done also focus on
energy efficiency you know when david
cameron famously said cut the green crap
i was one of our shadow ministers at the
time i used to say i was the shadow
minister for green crap in a way but you
know you're not saying that
you know the insulate britain had a
point do you i think there has to be a
huge focus on energy efficiency the
uk's housing stock for many reasons is
far less efficient compared to the rest
of continental europe so there are huge
things that can be done we believe you
could cut entire gas imports to the uk
by 15
by focusing on that so it's not small
beer this this is really significant
stuff the government's record on this
area is absolutely appalling let's see
some real action from them on that area
too jonathan reynolds good to have you
in the studio thanks for joining us